[Music]  this is Molly polypropylene  what you're looking at is Cleo the  clownfish who is made of garbage picked  up off of beaches and my job as an  artist is to figure out how to use it  and how to educate people so that we can  stop the plastic pollution problem in  the ocean I'm not standing in - well  bone ribcage that's all made of  detergent bottles fishing buoys crab  bait traps all this junk is in the ocean  these whales are actually washing up  with garbage in their bellies which is  really sad and it shouldn't be there  thousands of volunteers help us kids  help us I had a water bottle get soy  sauce to contain it everybody helps big  small parts of the sculpture  they're doing it in the fun way that  involves lots of people that is really  what watch the show is all about  [Music]  subscribe to my channel subscribe to my  channel subscribe to my channel  subscribe to my Channel please don't  make me keep going